so dry out here hi I'm Garrett and I'm
Nikki we're fascinated by how other
people live so we're going to try and
find some really interesting living
situations and live there experiencing a
totally different lifestyle to see which
one's will bring us closer together or
push us further apart
this week we're living in Arcosanti it's
really hard to explain but you're gonna
get the gist of it Asante what is it
Arcosanti is trying to demonstrate
something how to build a city as a
totally integrated single structure in
LA 15 is 60 70s there are a lot of
people who try to start like idealized
societies and this is that essentially
we are proving that you can live a rich
life without necessarily being rich and
without living in a development that is
negatively impactful on the earth these
are the vaulted arches this is
essentially our city centre we meet here
every morning during the week as a
community they've really thought very
practically about how to live in a
community and a space the notion of
community is one that we have
temporarily lost in America and it's one
that we hope our Kasana can serve as a
kind of a trigger for recovering the
entire structure here was built by the
people who live here there is a
fluctuating population around 60 to 80
people depending on how big our
workshops are I think it's like a work
live situation where everybody who lives
there also works and maybe helps build
it or tends to the plants or makes bells
this one in particular is our ceramic
studio where we make the
Ceramics Allari wind bells the structure
behind us is an apt shape for its
passive solar heating and cooling
techniques the Sun during the winter
will pass much lower in the sky so this
entire concrete structure will be filled
with sunlight heating the air inside of
the structure as much as 15 degrees so
the bells fund the architecture which
supports more manufacturing which sort
of says like this independent little
city a little bit yeah to take part in
the Arcosanti project you participate in
a five-week workshop which takes you
through the history of Arcosanti and
then for the last three weeks of your
workshop you come back here and you
practice a page in one of the
departments within the foundation
typically people go into construction
which if you guys are up for it will
have you work in construction tomorrow
awesome here's the thing I have a
master's degree in sustainable design
and construction that I don't do
anything with but it will be interesting
to see sort of what's going on in that
field and what these people are doing
the desert just seems like a scary place
to die it seems like one of those places
where humans should not be but if we
learn to live in the desert
maybe so these are housing and here
these are how that's out there that's
housing that's housing can I ask how
much like one of those spaces with rent
is it's $300 bucks Wow I don't think
Nikki's gonna like this Nikki doesn't
like meeting new people like at all so I
think she's gonna probably be running
away from that experience to a more
familiar one which is me so I think it's
going to push us closer together Garrett
will be the one person that I do know
and the one person I feel comfortable
with so you know if he and I stick
together it'll be fine you're staying in
different places from each other yes Oh
Oh on the second floor of this structure
we have three Co housing units one that
you're gonna be living in
oh my goodness
like very modern professional this is
very big guys this is so much bigger
than I thought it was going to be named
lifestyle just a little more efficient
you know this is one of our co housing
units it has five people living in it
okay two of which are married it has two
living spaces a large kitchen and two
bathrooms great this is actually a very
big shower will it be tall enough yeah
it's fine no shower in the world's tall
I'm worried that this is one of those
living situations where I'm not just
living with Garret I'm living with like
a lot of other people and you have your
own space very cozy yeah five counters
for all your files bathroom yeah gonna
work free yeah it definitely is great I
think we're ready
great have a wonderful evening have fun
you in your brand new spaces feel free
to roam around okay and tomorrow you
will be starting construction at 7:00
a.m. in the solar classroom 7 a.m. 7
a.m.
Oh
[Music]
all right two chairs for visitors oh
this is a very nice all right great hi
this is my bedroom and we're on the roof
this is this is a gorgeous place okay
now and I thought I was kind of scared
of the desert and I still have like this
is literally the view from my window and
that's pretty amazing
I'm kind of overwhelmed with information
but I don't really know how to reflect
on this so we're doing this right after
the RV which was a tough journey
Garrett and I are on okay terms I think
we're fine but it's definitely good that
I have my own space I'm sort of immersed
in it and I get to meet new people and
listen to their stories I watched the
football game tonight with a few people
and that was like a great way to get to
know some people over like something
that we all like to do it's like easy
for me to talk about football with
people I don't know here's all our
friends that Nikki's cheering on with
football tomorrow we're gonna be working
so like actually working like pouring
concrete which I'm really excited about
like I said I studied like concrete
design and like steel design stuff like
that but I never actually got to like do
it
it's a damn
[Music]
not only anybody else here we're gonna
be ready for construction
25 minutes
[Music]
it's dark and cold
[Music]
Construction is not really my thing
and I think that's okay all I see here
is I can hurt myself makes me very
nervous
these are some of those finished panels
that I showed you for East housing grass
and I've sanded before
yeah um Kelsey made our coffee table
really yeah who cement truck is here and
I'm terrified trucks gonna do most of
the work we're just gonna guide the
concrete into the friendship trench
Garrett seems to enjoy himself I think
he liked it a lot today I think he was
like very excited to get his hands in
that cement so much fun this is someone
it's like a violet and like you're
wrestling with the thing now I work
boots here I've got work boots weren't
sneakers it's going all right you're
doing good
you're getting in there
[Music]
how do you pick it up without it like
yeah kind of scrape it off the edge we
just finished construction it was a
little so much fun look my pants my
pants are ruined he looked like a little
kid who was like seeing his like
grown-up dreams fulfilled she was like a
great sport at it it's cool like we did
this thing and it's going to be a
permanent part of this place post
concrete pour rations nutrients
sustenance rib-sticking welcome to these
mark thank you it was really cool seeing
the archives today because understanding
the history of our course on tea helps
you understand the future of Arcosanti I
think is the point
it's about reorganizing a city to be
dimensionally everything here seems so
intentional and so like well-thought-out
I learned that my heated floors this
morning that I thought were just like a
weird surprise my for is very warm was
like an intentionally built in thing
through architecture and science so
stuff like that is like stuff I never
think about and it's something that I
got to experience today I've got a
little bit free time and I'm pretty
wiped out from all that work this
morning so I came back to my room just
to kind of regroup a little bit before
dinner
I like already been up for really long
time alone I played dinky links today it
was like fun it's like you get to see
sort of the community come together
outside of work where they need tomorrow
and garen I haven't spent a whole lot of
time together just us so maybe we'll
hang out tonight or maybe we'll hang out
tomorrow morning we haven't seen much of
each other outside of work um but she
loves video games and I bought a
Nintendo switch a couple days ago Nikki
don't we video games yep it's morning of
day three and floors I'm really good I
got dressed like I ready I'd made myself
some coffee and I'm like sitting on my
couch this is my ideal morning I'm sure
Garrett is up and about already we're
gonna see the foundry today Nikki and I
had a good time here she got to have her
privacy when she wanted I got to join in
with the hooligans in the community when
I wanted he did like hanging out a
little bit last night which I think was
that one-on-one time that we both enjoy
so it was great that we could fit that
in as well as I participate in a larger
community together I had so many cool
experiences here I got a joining
construction and crew for a day I got to
talk about architecture with a lot of
people that conversations I don't
usually get to have Arcosanti is kind of
like a futuristic city in the fact that
like people who come through here will
be thinking about how they live in the
future
because of what they do here I think
both Garrett and I had no idea what we
were getting ourselves into and came
here but I'm walking away with a lot
that I'm thinking about after being here
Eric's auntie I would love to feel a
bell I don't steal about all by Bell is
there a place we can buy Bell those
moles are cool they're everywhere you
can hear right now
next week on homebodies
[Music]
ah
and just sound like hard work we cooked
and dinner in the dark this feels like
the late 1800s I'm half covered in poop
I feel like my body's falling apart it's
so hard to live out here get out of here
leave me alone
[Music]